check this out this is from news 7
boston i don't exactly know why it's
from boston but
it's a certified news guard source and
they're telling us it's happening so
i'll take it even though the dnc is in
milwaukee
police agencies pulling out of
democratic convention
more than 100 police agencies are
withdrawing from agreements to send
personnel to bolster security at next
month's democratic national convention
in milwaukee
in part because they're concerned about
a recent directive ordering police in
the city
to stop using tear gas to control crowds
a citizen oversight commission last week
directed milwaukee's police chief to
publicly account
for why the department used tear gas
during protests in late may
and early june after the killing of
george floyd and to change milwaukee's
police policies
to ban the use of tear gas and pepper
spray the milwaukee fire and police
commission said in its order police
chief alfonso morales
could be fired if he fails to comply
that order came amid
intense scrutiny of police tactics in
portland oregon this we understand
they say since the milwaukee order was
issued more than 100 law enforcement
agencies in wisconsin and across the
country
decided against coming to milwaukee
morales told the wtmj
on tuesday they were concerned with
directives placed on on the police
department
including not allowing tear gas or
pepper spray now the tear gas thing i'm
kind of like
new york doesn't really use tear gas
okay i don't think chicago does either
and they're effective in their crowd
control new york
i don't new york does use pepper spray
but new york rarely
engages in that kind of tactic or weapon
you know sprays so i'm i'm almost like
is is that is that it
well think about the layout of new york
too i mean you're
you're closed in you know the the
streets are not
they are kind of wide in some areas but
you know you put a tear gas down it's
not just going to spread out
it's going to go up and into people's
windows and it does
buildings yeah so so the environment in
new york compared to where they're
actually using it like milwaukee
is significantly smaller and more open
so it can disperse a little bit more so
i can see how it being problem in bigger
cities a lot of people also don't
realize that tear gas has to go
somewhere it doesn't just
it's not just gone right all right so i
think for
new york and chicago there was an issue
with their plumbing systems oh okay yeah
it works
yep because new york is a big rock it
doesn't
absorb or anything it just goes into the
water yep just kind of so i don't i
don't know exactly yeah
it's actually you can actually look at a
map of manhattan this is really cool
and you can see a zigzag of skyscrapers
that's where the bedrock is
because they yeah so this the smaller
buildings are on the weaker ground and
then they build the skyscrapers on the
rock
yeah make sure you ever see the videos
of them doing the subways in new york
it's just a massive rock and then this
huge machine just ripping through it's
really cool actually cool yeah
anyway so they say the convention
scheduled for august 17th to the 20th at
wisconsin center in downtown milwaukee
has been scaled down to a mostly virtual
event with only about 300 people
expected to attend in person
most of the speeches will be delivered
online from other locations
though former vice president joe biden
has said he will be in milwaukee to
accept the nomination
despite the event's smaller scale police
are preparing for a potentially
for potentially large protests in and
around the venue
oh boy the left as you know i see
conservatives all the time
that the the far left antifa are the
democratic party
that's exactly what i was thinking
though like who's who's going to be
protesting this place
the far left and for what reason they
hate
the democrats or their passion in 2016
there was like 10 protesters at the rnc
okay it was boring and i was like wow
nothing i thought you know look i
thought the rnc
because of back in uh 2004 it was crazy
like i wasn't you know paying much
attention but there were people brought
molotovs and shields and they got
arrested by the fbi and a bunch of crazy
stuff like that
the dnc convention the rnc oh okay so
everybody thought that
2016's rnc was going to be crazy because
it was donald trump and everybody's like
oh no it's trump you know
he's a bad person and no no nobody
showed up
but you know what you know you know
where they did show up thousands of
people descended on the dnc
tried jumping barriers we're trying to
knock them down fighting with the police
what what was their message do they even
have one the dnc are the the people who
showed up to protest the dnc
it was i mean do they have to spit the
message
do they they they do but it's dejected
it's a bunch of different groups right
right for the most part it was the
democratic party
you know is complicit they think the the
democrat dems are evil
they still do you you you follow a lot
of these progressive personalities and
they will rip on the democrats all day
and night yeah
it's where we all get along the
corporate democrats are trash
and that's why i'm like who's voting for
biden because the progressives i really
do think
the far left at least some of them want
trump to win
did we talk about the other day a little
bit a couple times it's come up yeah
yeah uh i remember back in 2016 there
were some far leftists who hated trump
but told me they were going gonna vote
for him
like people i knew from occupy okay and
i laughed about it and they were like
hey man
they're like you get trump in it's all
gonna it's all gonna go down faster
and i was like you think that if you
vote for trump like the country is going
to fall apart and like oh definitely
because their view was like voting for a
a celebrity tv personality
over us you know hillary clinton who
worked in state department yeah was like
a sure path towards everything
crumbling and falling apart little did
they know right end up having the best
economy of our generation
yeah exactly well i mean their argument
now would be
no we were right that's what they're all
saying because of what's happening now
because of kovid
because of you know the riots they're
actually
i'm it's funny to see tweets now like
finally after three and a half years
where they're like
you know i knew trump the trump
presidency was was gonna be a disaster
i'm like oh shut up now you didn't we
had three years of the best economy
we've ever had
yeah and all you did was scream the
whole time and none of this is his fault
it's all
it's coveted and then democratic you
know leadership
being terrible at their jobs it is yeah
that's what's funny about
how they they're attacking him over the
federal deployment in portland
right because it's like you complain
that he's not doing anything
about the lockdowns like he should
mandate every state to do it yeah
then you complain when there's a small
group of people defending a courthouse
in portland
yep that's it that's that's just the
stupidest there's there's no way to win
rightly so
defending this courthouse because it's
being bombarded nightly
for weeks now how long has it been being
attacked
60 something days well that's that's
when the riots started in portland but
when
it was like the 30 well the the 39th is
when they breached the doors oh when
they didn't
started to fire inside a road okay okay
but they probably were attacking it
before that
right they were trying to set up
initially they were trying to set up the
the paz i guess the portland autonomous
zone
i don't know i so at least 30 days
though at least that this courthouse has
been
being attacked yep it's crazy and it's
funny how trump actually wasn't doing
anything
some some conservative personalities
were saying that trump was being told to
not engage because people liked the
protests
so trump basically was like okay and
then he made his stand now they're
trying to argue
that trump made his stand at mount
rushmore you know and he was
on july 3rd he's like we're going to do
this that and this the only problem
the riots had stopped trump was too late
with trump
it was a month earlier it was a month
before he even said anything he wasn't
he wasn't sending people out he said
it's it's up to the states and the
cities man
yeah they're the ones that take care of
it they've made it really clear over the
past couple months too that
we are in control you back off well i'll
tell you what's funny man
this is milwaukee where the democratic
national convention needs to have their
gathering they're gonna i don't know
what they're gonna do
i i i'll tell you what let me just let
me just speculate real quick
joe biden vows to be there there's going
to be massive protests
no one thinks joe like well a lot of
people think joe biden won't be the
nominee because it's just like
me i i don't think so that's me so is
there is there a possibility that
something happens there with a lack of
security that results in joe biden not
being the nominee
interesting that could result that could
result in a
massive boost in sympathy for the
democratic party i'm gonna need more
information
what are you speculating i'm speculating
that we're sending a very old and feeble
man
into the fray with no security is a
really really dumb idea
yeah joe biden absolutely must have
security and i'm sure he will have
secret service
hopefully that's enough they need their
police yeah this man needs to be
protected
you don't gotta like the guy to
recognize i don't care who you are in
politics
we can't have crazy people going around
doing crazy things that's absolutely
true
but i'll tell you what man if something
happens to joe biden
because this the cops say they're
pulling out i mean i'll be furious
yeah but i'll tell you what a lot of
people will be very very very
sympathetic to the democratic party
they will be well we're calling it here
you know so
i'm not calling anything i'm saying like
i'm saying all right well i'm i'm
through you i'm saying if that happens
we
already called it out and see it ahead
of time and it's like
it's not even it's not even rather
conspiratorial we got it it hasn't got
to say no it isn't it's absolutely not
conspiratorial to say
no sending in a presidential candidate
into a city that expects large protests
with no police presence is one of the
stupidest things you can do
and i tell you what it's it's it's it's
not conspiratorial at all to say
loathsome you know greatly loathed
obama administration vp no police
large protests very dangerous for an old
man
very dangerous i don't know so if i said
my grandpa walked into a crowd of antifa
throwing bricks at people's faces you'd
be like that's a conspiracy theory if he
dies
i'd be like i'm not i'm not even gonna
say that i just think that uh biden's
gonna go out and
announce his retirement i think that's
that's been what i've been saying for a
long time
i i see what you're saying okay i i
i don't think that's gonna i don't think
that's gonna happen i think that he's
gonna have his own
entourage and roll in dues
you know they retire and roll out the
amount of security they have for
buildings
that they use for these conventions is
is absurd they do like
full dog sweeps three times they have to
lock down every door well if the police
aren't coming they're not gonna have
that
i mean they'll probably have feds to
take care of some of it
okay but they need they need police
that i do agree and they don't have it
because of their own policies now back
in chicago
well this doesn't say that no police
will be there it's
a hundred different agencies have said
that we're we're we don't want to be
there
because of of these specific things you
know that's not to say that they're not
even going to show up
it's that they're upset that they can't
control a crowd like they would like to
if they if they needed to so they're
calling attention to
a specific problem that they see because
they're police and they've
probably dealt with this many times
before so they know what's coming
they're just covering themselves i don't
blame them at all
this is interesting it says not all
police departments withdrew because of
tear gas
apparently does this mean there's no
police says madison withdrew because of
kovid
madison originally committed to
providing 100 officers to milwaukee
for what was maybe they're only
referring to this group but
this is interesting i don't know they
say that uh
fond du lac police chief
william lam told the milwaukee journal
sentinel that the agreements were
collapsing saying he
expects other agencies in the states to
also withdraw lamb chairs the wisconsin
police executive group
which is made up of police chiefs from
cities with populations of more than 20
000 people
lamb sent a letter to milwaukee police
in july 6 outlining his organization's
concerns about limiting the use of tear
gas and pepper spray
west allis police firsted a letter to
morales with concerns
yeah and they basically say the same
thing i i think they would just cancel
it i really do i think they'll make it
virtual i think you're right i think
that that there's
the chances of them just going no police
all right well the dnc will just go
online
and biden can stay in his basement
exactly they're going to keep him in his
basement that's serious yep
they're going to that's all they've been
doing there's no do
and now and now there's probably not not
even going to be a debate
and because of kovid trump can't have
rallies yeah this is a ridiculous
election cycle man
you know the the anything to shut him
down anything that's what
that's what a lot of people are saying
like all of this is ridiculous they just
want to
try to be trump in any way possible and
what i've been saying for
months now they're filing firing on all
cylinders firing every single thing they
got because
they know the average americans like
trump's
trump's good we like trump we like our
economy we like making money we like
being
safe in our homes we could we could uh
we could get a little conspiratorial and
argue that the democratic governors
are colluding to restrict trump's
abilities to campaign
and they're trying to destroy the
economy we could get conspiratorial
but i don't think we need to my question
is why is that andrew cuomo will allow
black lives matter rallies and protests
bill de blasio will
and then condemn some you know uh some
like an outdoor concert which is the
same same same thing basically
why why did phil murphy the governor of
new jersey have these two gym owners
arrested
meanwhile the gym is literally connected
to a dollar general with probably
hundreds of thousands of people coming
in and out every day
and they wanted to have a small handful
of people like a private limited
membership
thing for their gym they got arrested
why that makes no sense yeah the
hypocrisy is real
we see it all over the place and people
are seeing it i'll tell you what man
i am i am i'm one of those people that
absolutely hates
conspiracy theories okay and i i i want
evidence to lead me to the conclusion
yep but with as crazy as everything has
been over the past few months
i've never been more conspiratorial and
there are some other journalists and
high profile like political
personalities i've texted with
and they all basically feel the same way
like how is this possible
how are all of these things you know
what man
i just can't buy it okay why why would
they allow black lives matter protests
and then argue that everything else has
to be shut down
because the black lives matter protests
were helping the democrats yeah exactly
it's it's a fact gallup just released a
poll saying two out of three people
supported the protests
so even people who understood that covid
was bad apparently agreed
or the polls are wrong cause i'll tell
you what man
i can't imagine being somebody who got
fired from your job and then going
i'm not allowed to work but i love the
protests i'm not i'm not allowed to go
to church
but i love the protests i love the
protest i can't go to a funeral
my my father is getting chemo on a
deathbed but i love the protests i don't
buy it
how many people have i how many stories
have i heard of people not even allowed
to go visit their
dying parents that then ended up dying
and they weren't even able to say
goodbye just because
they weren't allowed to go to the
hospital by themselves
alone to visit their dying parents
how many but and yet these people are
out marching together dancing
in the streets with no masks it's like
yep
i want a state there's nothing wrong
with peaceful protesting that is not
what we're talking about
i love people we are talking about the
hypocrisy of
allowing the protests and not allowing
anything else
that's the problem and now they're
locking everything down again
exactly and they're printing money how
about that
i hope you guys are buying your gold
because they're coming to print your
money or whatever it's the opposite of
stealing your money
yeah you see alex jones you say they
were going to snatch up your income tax
no they're just making your money worth
nothing they're just making it rain
yeah trying to buy it all while you can
because the dollars
yeah gold's going up i guess bitcoin i
have no idea man
when i when i found out that they were
gonna start printing money again
i was like i look at my facebook and i
see all my progressive friends cheering
like yay print more money and i'm like
you really have no idea how money works
no they don't they don't i'm not going
to pretend like i'm chief economist at
any
principal at any prestigious
organization
but i can understand the concept of
supply and demand and if
you just keep printing out money and
then stores say they can't accept cash
that's the freaky thing i'm like the how
are you gonna spend the dollar you know
so
so there's there's reports going around
that because of the coin shortage
some stores are saying straight up no
cash accepted anymore
so here something in this okay if if my
local stores won't accept cash because
there's no coins
so what i i hire like someone to mow my
lawn they walk up and they're like
that'll be 50 bucks and i pull out a you
know
50 billion they go what am i supposed to
do with that
well it's money i know but i can't spend
it can you just paypal me or something
you'd be like oh yeah i guess all of a
sudden the cash becomes worthless
yeah and every single transaction with
anything is
suddenly now tracked man i'm glad i got
bitcoin
i don't got a lot but i'm glad i got
cryptocurrencies
not that i'm super confident in those
necessarily
but they're just one form of easy to
transfer you know value
and we'll see man this is uh truly truly
unprecedented
indeed thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you